foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__] this
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
thank you
CPAC
[Music]
Ah that's the joke that's it that's the
joke seat back that's the entry
oh my God you thought we were gonna run
out of boneheads this week you really
thought we were gonna run out of
boneheads this week oh baby seat pack is
on
and it's full of [__] boneheads of
course it is
they're the real America verse Maga Nazi
party so why wouldn't there be just a
shitload
a boneheads
you know one
um specific person who is not going to
seat back which I think is very
significant
is Ron desantos meatball Ron as he's
known meatball run is not attending CPAC
today apparently now we're gonna have
plenty of sound bites we've already got
Jim Jordan being hailed by Matt Slap the
sexual molester
a legend allegedly okay
[Laughter]
he's a republican right
um
you have him calling Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan the most powerful man
in Washington as if that's like a great
attribute they're like oh yeah
we they we have so much power
to what yep you haven't you haven't
gotten Hunter Biden arrested yet
you haven't impeached and removed Joe
Biden you have not ascended the orange
Mussolini Jesus to his throne
how much power do you does Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan actually have
other than to make clips
for Fox News
I mean that's it that that really is Jim
Jordan's
superpower other than not reporting sex
crimes I mean that's a hell of a
superpower Jim Jordan has that [__]
scumbag
and then we have Scott Perry Oh Scott
Perry oh boy I don't know if you heard
of this [__] treasonous piece of [__]
he's fighting really hard for the
Department of Justice not to look at his
phone at the evidence of how he
committed sedition he's really he's
working really hard in court and today
at CPAC he's projecting his fear that
the Department of Justice is going to
jail him
for his sedition
so much so that he is threatening he is
threatening to make sure
that they don't get building leases for
government agencies I'm not [__] you
I'm not kidding you on the same [__]
breath he is threatening it
these [__] chuckleheads man and I'm
gonna talk about big government small
government today and what these [__]
idiots had convinced brain dead
moglodytes out there of
how they've convinced them and it plays
into this stupid bigoted [__]
narrative and we're also going to watch
a video today
speaking of bigoted narrative blowing up
in their [__] face we're gonna watch
a video from a hearing
in Missouri
or some scumbag representative she's
trying to write a bill
that sexualizes lgbtq relationships but
not heterosexual relationships because
she wants to make sure to get rid of all
all existence
of any mention of lgbtq relationships in
Missouri schools it's the don't say gay
bill in Missouri basically I mean that's
what it is
Missouri's trying to out Florida Florida
it's kind of what it is but in this clip
you're gonna watch her stumble
over her own [__] logic
folks this is what I've been talking
about I've been telling you this for a
long time this fascism [__] that they're
trying it just ain't gonna work
and I know it feels like it's a long
hard fight because it is
because their voters are mind [__]
they're delusional they're willing to
vote for them based on affiliation alone
not based on facts not based on what is
best for them the constituents
and it's it's gonna be a long hard
battle and we have to fight it every
single [__] day that is why I'm here
every single [__] day for two hours a
day Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch I need to do self-promotion
but you know what you surely should if
you're not already subscribe to the
YouTube channel it's [__] free this
show is free for two hours every single
day [__] free
and I emphasize the [__] part
but that's why we have to fight every
single day
every last one of them because they're
not gonna stop
they're not going to stop I'm going to
show you evidence today of how they
don't give a [__] how scummy you know
they are they don't give a [__] you're
gonna have mat slap who is under right
now under sexual assault allegations
who run CPAC who's not right running and
hiding underneath a rock because of
these allegations he's up on stage with
a guy who didn't report sex crimes for
his student athletes
and he's like yeah woo I'm so excited to
be here two sexual assaulters people who
don't report sex crimes on stage we're
the most powerful people in in the
[__] manga party
it's something else man it is something
else
it is it is a crazy [__] time that we
live in what a time to be alive we are
at the intersection of WrestleMania in
real life
in no real
reality would that happen
people who know who know who these
[__] scumbags are would never be
cheering that those two [__]
are standing on cage patting each other
on the on
on the [__] there I I called the
um CPAC full of Maga losers but the
the thumbnail is CPAC em on the [__]
ass [__]
I don't know
what do you want me to do
that was not that was me that was not
Gabe Sanchez the wording he did the
thumbnail he did the art I just came up
with the idea of the
I don't know
I don't know she pack him by the [__]
ass [__] hey speaking of
today we were gonna put out merch
on our merch store and it's spring.com
or teespring.com and I'm not knocking
them at all maybe
um and I'm gonna appeal it today I
promise I just didn't have time
yesterday afternoon to appeal it once
they turned down my listing I put up
here's we put up uh let me find some
[__] there it is here's that [__] ass
[__] 45 uh art that Gabe Sanchez made
for our merch
and I put it up there
and they rejected it almost immediately
so I don't know what it was I don't know
if I I didn't say [__] ass or [__] in
the listing like I didn't spell out
those words and it there's nothing
offensive I mean other than the [__]
ass [__] 45's face it's [__]
offensive as [__]
he didn't like it I just it was a
sticker that's all it was that's what I
started with it was a sticker I was
doing a sticker in a coffee mug
to start out with yesterday and
I turned down my listing
hey girl I'm gonna peel it today because
there's I I mean I don't think there's
anything as copyright in there other
than
you know I don't know if someone has PAB
copyrighted [__] ass [__] I have no
idea PAB 40 I don't know what it is so
I'm gonna try to investigate that today
but they turned down my listing my guess
is my guess is it's because Trump is a
[__] ass [__] and that's why they
[__] turn down my listing is because
they're [__] scared of being canceled
even though that's what they do they
literally literally
sell a Republican party all around the
country these [__] fascist
are trying to legislate people out of
existence I I'm not [__] you they
existence and not just trans people
folks forget that [__] they are going
after the lgbtq community in full and
that is their War to go after women to
go after all Democrats everywhere any
person that's a liberal thinking they
want rid of them in Florida there is a
bill being introduced in Florida to ban
and to cancel they say the word canceled
the Democratic party in Florida
that they they
don't want Democrats to exist they don't
want lgbtq people to exist they don't
want women to exist without them
believing only men are the ones white
men should be in power
they don't want people of color to exist
they just don't want it they don't want
indigenous people to exist they don't
want brown people to exist they don't
want it and they are going to do
everything they can to legislate them
out of existence they're trying it
I told you this last year all year last
year that they are going to try to do it
and they continue this this long hard
slog of fascism in our state houses
that's where they're doing it
it's where they're trying to get this
done
they passed an anti-drag bill in
Tennessee as the governor of of [__]
Tennessee is exposed for oh my God can
you believe
he dressed up as a woman oh my god oh as
if that's some kind of [__] news but
it is news because they're making it a
[__] felony
because it's not about laws for thee
or me excuse me it's about laws for thee
you you [__]
Governor Bill Lee can dress up as a
woman if he wants he's a cyst white male
and he's the governor he gets to do [__]
like that just like there's a
representative down in Texas wouldn't
you know Texas is trying to do the same
[__] thing huh isn't that something
isn't that something that all these red
states are out trying to Hitler Hitler
oh excuse me Ron DeSantis
what the [__] you want from me I ain't
doing this [__] I'm just [__]
commentating on it
there's a represented put out a video
apparently he dressed up in women's
clothing too oh my God he dressed up in
women's clothing
Say It Ain't So I ask him what his
[__] drag name was
I we we know we know
we know why they're passing these bills
other than they want to exterminate
groups of people in this country because
they're absolutely obsessed
absolutely obsessed with their own
sexuality and their own sexual confusion
which is a them problem it is a friend
if you listen if you are if you are
concentrating more
on trans people gay people lesbians
bisexuals
anything to do with outside what you
figure is your normal sexuality it is a
you problem
so you probably none of them problem
as long as those people aren't
committing egregious crimes
leave them the [__] alone
you being obsessed with someone else's
genitalia tells us a lot about you
maybe we should be checking your laptop
I forget the guy's name I don't know
what the [__] his name is some [__]
scumbag white dude from Texas wouldn't
you know it
well let me see if I can find it here of
course kellyanne Conway's in the Nate
his name is Nate
I'm going to show you that today I'm
going to show you that and then that you
got um you got excuse me Marjorie Taylor
green
and Kelly and I'm getting them confused
Marty Taylor Green kellyanne Conway I
mean
you know what am I supposed to do how
can you keep track of these [__]
troglodytes but Mark uh that there you
go again
kellyanne Conway that's what I meant to
say
um goes on Fox News and really is
begging people begging begging them to
believe the delusion even on Fox News
they're losing the plot every single day
little by little by little by little and
I keep telling you this they can't hang
on to this this nonsense they're not
gonna be able to hang on to it as long
as they keep doing
the thing that they're doing where
they're trying to out fascist the next
fascist it's not going to go well for
them but it has to be you it is you that
stands in their way
it is you that stands in their way
it's not going to be their own party
it's not going to be their own voters
they're not going to stand in their way
hell they're cheering it
people are demented
they've been mind [__] for years by
right-wing talk radio
mind [__] just completely deluded
and then when Trump came along and there
was a cult available for it oh my God
they bought in hell yeah they wanted a
cult why not it was basically a cult
before without the leader
then they finally had themselves a snake
oil leader for the cult
but of course of course it's going to be
on you
the pro-democracy Coalition and you have
to build it stronger and bigger than we
did the last time I'm guessing I'm
guessing
that we're gonna have probably I would
say about 14 million in the margin from
Trump to Biden
because get it out of your [__] head
there ain't no way that Trump is not
going to be the nominee
there's a lot of talk this morning about
the Manhattan DA's office they're going
to file a felony
based on
some testimony that may or may not
happen in a grand jury by Michael Cohen
possibly kellyanne Conway apparently
she's
I've been having to talk to
the Manhattan DA's office about a
payment
a hush money payment that Michael Cohen
went to federal prison for
um and it looks like the evidence that
Alan Bragg might have in the grand jury
testimony that might be given to this
new grand jury could slam Dunkle felony
charge for that check now whether that
comes before or after Jack Smith's uh
indictments so the indictments in
Georgia which are coming
coming folks and I know I know the media
is telling you all kinds of crazy ass
[__] they're [__] trying to make you
think yeah oh the FBI is corrupt oh my
god listen I I've gotten personal phone
calls one this morning concerning
whether the FBI is corrupt and they try
to cover step up and is this a sign that
Trump's not going to be listen listen
[__] listen to me really good
and clear
the fear of independent FBI agents of
having retribution against them because
they do their job was not outdone by the
doj
there was a [__] there was a [__]
search warrant based on three goddamn
criminal statutes that an FBI agent took
to a federal judge and that federal
judge issued that search warrant and
they executed that search warrant
that that case and that search warrant
is now under a special counsel's belt
and remember the special counsel is no
no just any normal [__]
and no former FBI director this is a God
damn war criminal prosecutor okay he's a
professional prosecutor that prosecutes
war criminals all right
this is not just some dumb [__] off the
street
mayor Garland picked someone to do this
and yesterday after watching mayor
Garland get [__] yelled at because
he's
these moglodytes want [__] they want
to get on Tucker's show because the only
person that could get on Tucker's show
is Tulsi gabbard and Marjorie Taylor
green at this point
Ted Cruz desperately trying to get back
on Tucker's show oh man I want to be on
White Privilege tonight bad so I'll yell
and scream at the Attorney General Tom
Cotton and Josh Hawley the like
[__] that mayor Garland was having none
of it yesterday and for you out there
that think Merrick Garland is some kind
of weak piece of [__] man you you just
you are not paying attention you weren't
watching the Clips yesterday
that is not a guy who's bending to the
pressure
of rather not to prosecute someone
because they committed crimes
and I don't give a [__] who goes first
whether it's the Manhattan DA's office
whether it's Georgia or it's Jack Smith
I don't give a [__] because it doesn't
matter because let me tell you something
and I told this to the person this
morning stop watching MSNBC stop
listening to the [__] news that the
journalists that are out there are not
doing their [__] jobs
they're not when you're questioning
rather the FBI being fearful of trump
had anything to do with this case you're
not getting to the fact the fact of the
matter is that an FBI agent took those
three charges to a federal judge and
that search warrant was issued and
executed and now is being investigated
and Donald Trump is fearful as [__] I
don't know if you've been watching his
true social page we've been following
him here on fraud social and I've read
you several of them he is terrified
[__] terrified
every time he speaks he projects his
fear of Jack Smith
he knows what documents he took he knows
why he took them he know what he knows
what he was trying to cover up
the same thing that Scott Perry says
today
his same fear
they tried to commit sedition
they tried to overturn our constitution
to overturn your vote to overthrow our
government
that's what they did and that's what he
is hiding with those documents among
other things I believe
there's a lot of reasons why he took
those [__] documents but the reason
why Jack Smith has purview over the
documents case
and the January 6th case is because it's
the same [__] thing
same
and to believe to believe
that somehow somehow someway oh oh
there's never gonna be just the serve
there's a two-tier justice system in
this country
but certainly there's more than a
two-tier justice system in this country
we've known this for a long time us as
liberals have been screaming about it
have you ever watched a video of a black
man being [__] murdered because he's
black by a police officer just because
he's a cop and that [__] and that guy
is black have you ever seen it I've seen
it I think we saw it in the summer of
2020.
and you don't and and you're confused
about a different tiered justice system
sure
I'll agree with that fact but what does
that have to do what does that have to
do or negate the facts that are before
you
three criminal statutes on that
document's case and we have no idea I
mean the only reason why we know about
the [__] the the search warrant in
the first place and what they took and
what they didn't take or what they could
take what they found is because of
Trump's big ass mouth
the one thing you don't know let me tell
you something you don't know
you don't know what they have on January
6. why is Scott Perry fighting so
[__] hard to hide his cell phone
he's fighting really hard to hide his
cell phone it's almost
it's almost like
he's trying as hard as Trump tried not
to get back the documents
it's almost like that if it feels to me
like they're hiding I don't know crime
so stop being stop being such a weak ass
[__] ass [__] do not be like them and
certainly
certainly do not
do not transmit their narratives and
their talking points and I'm talking
about the right wing when you're talking
about how the FBI is derelict in its
Duty and it's doing everything it can to
not prosecute Donald Trump you are
playing into their narrative
that's right
that's right you're helping them dummy
do you want to help the fascists do you
want to help the Nazis huh
hey you know what I actually what I want
and they've been doing it a lot here
lately and I'm going to encourage it
more and more I'm gonna get the Nazis to
punch the Nazis that's what I'm gonna
hypothetically speaking like you know
not not I I mean I mean I I wouldn't
I would never I'd buy tickets
to watch a bunch of knights Nazis in a
cage fight it out wouldn't you I would I
mean who doesn't like to see a Nazi get
their clock cleaned all right I'm here
for it
but politically we need to get them to
punch each other and they're doing a
bang-up job of it folks all we have to
do is keep encouraging them and
encouraging them encouraging encouraging
because I keep telling you it does not
matter what indictments come
it does not matter
it doesn't matter what indictments come
it is only going to strengthen Trump's
base around him
did you watch the [__] video of Brian
Kilmeade in Florida Florida in a diner
walking around trying to get white
people to say that they'd vote for
DeSantis even the woman with the
DeSantis shirts like maybe I might vote
for him
it depends on if Donald Trump is on the
ballot too is what she meant to say
it's only going to secure his nomination
when he's indicted
[__] doubt me you [__] doubt me
I'm gonna be here right here on this
microphone telling you that I told you
so I told you when he got indicted that
it's only going to strengthen his
[__] support it's only going to
secure him to be the nominee of the
Republican Party
he will be the [__] nominee I'm gonna
say it every [__] day until it
happens
who else is going to be the nominee
Brian Kilby on Fox News these are Fox
News loyal [__] Watchers
Fox News has been doing its best to
undermine Trump can't do it
they even go to a diner
and they can't get a woman in a [__]
DeSantis shirt to go against Trump
it's not gonna happen folks
get it out of your minds I I seriously
doubt that Ron DeSantis even takes the
chance of running everyone again oh he's
gonna it's gonna be June or July June or
July you're gonna wait that long
to lose Ron meatball you really are
gonna wait that long what the [__]
dude you better be drumming up all the
support you can if you're gonna actually
run for president because he's not
he's waiting he's laying in the grass
waiting for Donald Trump to die
just in case just in case Ron's gonna be
there to snatch it away if if the old
big guy chokes on a Big Mac and dies
before he hits the floor I mean we can
only hope
I'm just saying I mean are you against
that I'm not against that I mean [__]
I just I'm just saying clogged arteries
is a hell of a way to go
I don't wish anything on anybody but
I would be a goddamn shame you're gonna
also be a shame if you miss a single
episode of this show that would be a
goddamn shame you should be here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch thank you for
joining us and thank you for chatting
with the best audience in the world on
YouTube it's free go to go to YouTube
and just search the Tony Michaels
podcast
and you can hit the Subscribe button hit
the like button go back to all the
episodes I don't know [__] go back to
all the episodes hit the like button
yeah you can certainly you can go back
and rank all the episodes
on all your accounts on all your Google
accounts that you get
ow [__] YouTube's gonna ban me too I've
I'm really surprised that uh I thought
it was the PAB thing is the reason why
they banned the merch [__] ass [__]
and of course you know I I I say that
but I don't put it on the thumbnail the
words PAB is on the thumbnail and that's
not the words
so I I you know I'm surprised YouTube
hadn't already shut me off maybe maybe
they will
uh they they've they've banned several
of our episodes deleted them they delete
them when they find them like oh [__]
this [__] I'm gonna turn this guy off
they delete it they cut it out I can't
even watch it well I mean I can go back
and watch it in like a review process
but I can't even watch it like I can't
even watch my own [__] video on
YouTube
isn't that crazy
they've
I don't know how long I'll be on YouTube
that's why what you should do is
subscribe because they don't [__] with
big accounts YouTube does it I mean as
much right I'm still considered a small
account we got just a little less than
15 000 subscribers
if we had like I don't know if we had
you know 800 000 a million a couple
million subscribers and they'd be less
likely to [__] with me you know what I
mean because they know I get a lot of
eyeballs but I'll tell you something
about um our analytics on YouTube and I
want to tell you why I'm super excited
and the reason why I have such fire in
my belly for the narrative and and
pushing for 2024 to make sure that we
bury these fascists once and for all and
for good
I doubt we will it's it's hard to kill
an idea it really is these ideas are
going to live forever they're bigots
what are you gonna do there's always
going to be bigots we just have to
combat against them with our narrative
and our messaging
but here's why I'm excited
over the last 28 days I looked at the
analytics I think I told you this the
other day the audience is staying about
the same size which feels disappointing
right it kind of we're not growing as
much in the last month that's okay you
know what I noticed
we have significantly increased
our watch time a lot like thousands tens
of thousands of hours
so same size audience more people are
watching longer
and it's super important that is very
very very [__] important to messaging
a narrative
what it tells me is this
is that you guys the audience who is
watching
is paying attention the entire time
wants to continue watching wants to
continue to listen
that is a great Mark for the future
not just not just for 2024 but into the
Future Past that because I'm not going
to stop doing this
and they may have to wheel me out in a
gurney
before I stop talking into this
microphone about the things I want to
talk about that I think are important to
our democracy and defending and saving
it
not just now but into the future
wherever that may take me and take you
but the important thing is that you're
listening longer more
every single day
you know why that is it's because of the
format
it's because of the show it's
entertaining I designed it that way it's
the whole point
is to get you to listen to engage
the chat is highly engaging
highly engaging that is you that's the
audience I'm not in the chat that often
I don't type much in there we do the uh
the talk or shoot the [__] now
on occasion
but you guys are talking to each other
that's the most important thing
that this show
is catapulting
with the amount of hours that you're
watching
huge
and it's you it's I it's not me I mean
yeah I come here and talk every day but
if you don't watch
you don't listen
I mean
does a tree really make a sound in the
woods if no one's around to hear it
on the tree and you're the people around
to hear it
and yes it does make a noise and we need
to make more and more noise every single
day that is why you come here every
single day
and we're gonna go through some video
clips CPAC boy it's rolling in as we go
we're probably going to be watching
clips
that are minutes old minutes old today
in the shitless Roundup so don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
these messages
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slam gems
skull
near on a Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more than Doritos you like the red bag
not the live love and blue one in your
absence I discovered a rash on my neck
and no it ain't no hickey and I even
seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
Patty Thursday Hattie Hattie Hattie
Point tomorrow's Friday
and you get ready for the weekend get
ready for bonehead of the week
and we're gonna have plenty of boneheads
holy [__] we're gonna have plenty of
bone-ins don't forget to go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod And
subscribe here on YouTube the Johnny
Michaels podcast that is where you vote
for bonehead of the week
later on today or sometime tonight
depending on that
uh when or if we forget then how late it
is thank you moderators uh for pointing
out when we
forget to jump on the uh
bone in the wheat Pole and is where
you'll vote for bone end of the week on
the community tab on YouTube or on
Twitter so don't forget to uh subscribe
they're both free it's free follow us
there I mean unless you're like a blue
subscriber if you do that stupid [__] it
cost you 8.99 or whatever it is
to pay Elon but you don't have to pay
Elon to follow us you don't have to
um might not end up in your uh your
algorithm as much but you know it
happens whatever [__] uh you can
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast every single
afternoon when we're done
uh recording and editing on Apple's
Spotify Google and it's [__] free
over there too didn't cost you a single
nickel to go subscribe and re-listen to
the show in audio form
and also follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels follow us there if you're
on Facebook right now hey if you can
hear me and you're on Facebook go follow
our page at the Tony Michaels and
[__] link is at the top of that
listing
go follow us Apes come on come on follow
if you got a Facebook account you still
got one come follow us
also you can find us on the up wires
YouTube channel just go to upwire.com
you find the link to the YouTube channel
for upwire it's a it's a commentators
YouTube channel
a Creator Channel you can also follow us
on Twitch did you know this is another
freeway this is kind of cool this is
another very free way
to give money
monetary support this this is what we do
for a living
this is what we do for a living
and this is one way that you can send
monetary support to the show and it
doesn't cost you a nickel and actually
you give us Jeff Bezos
his [__] money
if you got an Amazon Prime account you
just go log into twitch
with your Amazon Prime account
and you get one free subscription and
that subscription gives us a couple
bucks a month it really it's it's a
couple bucks a month but it they all add
up they all count
they all count keeps me talking that's
the most important thing it didn't cost
you a nickel than what you're already
spending on your Amazon Prime if you're
not giving away that subscription on
Twitch so check that out and you can
actually
put up a video
on my patreon uh all the members to the
patreon out there you will notice I put
up a video on how to do that
because some people are asking like I
want to do it but how do you do it so I
found a video on YouTube that explains
how to give away your one free Amazon
Prime subscription on Twitch and the
video does a pretty good job of it so
you can go check out patreon at
patreon.com Tony Michaels or just go to
the Tony michaels.com every single link
is there you know what I might put a
link to that video on the Tony
michaels.com
just go to the attorney michaels.com and
I might put a link to that so you can do
that I'll think about that we'll get
that done maybe later on today
I know we said we'd have the [__] ass
[__] 45 uh merch and I apologize we're
going to appeal it today
because we really like this design so
we're not sure if it's the design
what I have no idea I just don't know I
have no clue but but we're gonna we're
gonna pee let's see if we can get that
listing back up so as soon as I get the
listing back up I'll let you guys know
once we have that available but in the
meantime you can go to store not the
Tony michaels.com grab me some Surf's Up
[__] merch uh that's
store.the20michaels.com that's another
way that gives us great support
it's another way then you get something
you get some merch to wear also people
were asking about the [__] em hats if
you go to the tonymichaels.com there's
the hat store see the hat right here see
the red hat see that Boop the [__] and
there's another [__] hat right up
here right there
about the [__] em hats there's a hat
store it's a different store so that's
why they don't ban me over there
and the reason why is because I wanted
this specific hat
uh to put [__] them on because that's
the hats that I like
so that way you get the hat that I like
so we got different hat store so go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the attorney
michaels.com all the links are there to
the merch store the hat store
and the patreon thank you very much for
your support whether it's money or not I
I love all of your support
like and sharing retweeting when you
guys tag me
uh it's it's great it's fantastic you're
the best audience in the world and the
most important thing is that you're here
every day engaging
it's the most important thing we have to
engage
we have to engage in our democracy a lot
of people are saying [__] them hands
[__] them hands [__] match yeah you
can go get you some [__] mats just go
to the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you'll see the hat store
also Gabe's merch store
his merch is there too
on on the attorney michaels.com you can
find all the merch stores there's three
of them there's the the store there's
the hat store and then there's games so
go check that out beat Tony michaels.com
and quit yelling
are you talking to me
quit yet what the hell did you come here
for if you don't come here to hear me
yell
what the [__]
quit yelling who wants me to quit
yelling
I know I'm gonna do that [__] I
seriously doubt it you're gonna turn
down the goddamn volume if you can't
handle how much I yell it's just gonna
have to it's just gonna happen yes it
sounds to be that way oh someone says
louder goddamn right turn that [__]
volume up
look in the beginning of the show every
day
it gives you a disclaimer every day says
we're loud we're proud and we do not
give a [__]
and I don't I I live by that
because the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not
Liberty it just isn't and I'm gonna show
you a clip today
and I'm hoping we can start there and
then we'll go to the seat back [__]
well the CPAC stuff uh after that
um so thank you art music too for the
encouragement of being louder
as if
[Music]
as if I need any encouragement the
mighty librarian said I'd worry if Tony
didn't yell it'd be really suspicious
it'd be really suspicious
if uh if I weren't yelling
[Laughter]
oh my God
so uh let's let's see oh where is where
is Sanchez oh okay you'll be on here in
just a minute Sanchez is on his way he's
on his way don't worry don't fret if
you're looking
for the hunk of of Mexican love Gabe
Sanchez he is on his way I know I know a
lot of you in the chat love Gabe Sanchez
I don't I don't know this sh I don't
know that this show would survive
um without without Gabe Sanchez a lot of
people oh my God there's a lot of people
that I mean some people comment about my
haircut but
I'm telling you this chant loves
um some some Gabe Sanchez um
big Steph says um
the hunk of Mexican love I'm gonna tell
him I'm gonna tell him we we've deemed
him then hunk of Mexican love
it's true right uh See Art music here
love Gabe and Tony and see now I get
second fiddle it's all right I'm I'm
okay with that I'm okay with it I'm all
right all right that's um Amanda thank
you ah Tony we love you yes
we love Gabe Sanchez here right Gabe is
is great
that's someone's saying let's see if I
get it here we are on Twitch
you guys out there on Twitch twitch is
growing like crazy
those numbers I was telling you about
earlier those are YouTube numbers
um the the amount of watch time versus
how many people are watching it on
YouTube the amount of people watching it
on YouTube is almost exactly the same I
think that's the algorithm doing that to
be quite honest with you
it's like it feeds it to a certain
amount of people and that's it right
that just like a certain amount of
people per month
and that's it
and then and but our watch time is way
up
so the algorithms feed it to the same
amount of people but those people
they're feeding it to are watching way
longer
way longer
so I I don't know
again
YouTube hates my [__] guts because I
curse
and we say the truth the way that needs
to be said
as opposed to giving you all kinds of
[__]
just just the way it is so
but twitch the numbers are going up
there boom boom boom boom boom I mean by
percentage-wise
and I think I think um I think we should
uh continue to grow on all these
platforms
and I don't want to ignore any platform
Facebook I mean I hate Facebook
but I can't ignore it we got to make
sure we get this word out to everyone we
possibly can
um big stuff
you're after my uh I heard you Tony is a
hunk of redneck love
um I want to be clear about something
that I am a hillbilly first
um I redneck is something like yourself
proclaimed right like you're you're
proud kind of thing hillbilly you just
is and I is a hillbilly okay that's just
how it is so just want to make that
clear oh here is the here is the hunk of
Mexican love and everyone's uh here he
is here he is Gabe Sanchez what I I I
said that you were the hunk of Mexican
love oh man they loved it in the chat so
yeah
um fans out there that um consider you a
hunk oh well thank you so much everyone
who said that
you know what we haven't talked much I
pointed out your hat the other day but
uh talk more where do you find that
because you sent a picture of that to me
tell us a story about that hat you've
been wearing it so uh it might be my new
favorite hat okay well we kind of
noticed that [__] we noticed
that you've been wearing it all that's
why I'm saying something yeah yeah uh
all right so I was in Portland and I was
visiting some friends okay
um because are these are these wokers
are these wokers they're they're wokers
and they're definitely midnight tokers
oh okay uh uh yeah so I was originally
supposed to go up there to go visit them
for New Year's but God coven so
wow so I had to find a weekend at work
so my partner and I went up there the
other day for President's Day weekend
and
um
my group of friends like that I used to
live with we always will basically find
an excuse to like play dress-up you know
like we'll go get a costume oh okay like
that's what I mean look right
play house like when you're oh no no no
you remember that you remember that when
you're in yeah yeah I never heard the
mom I'm the dead yeah baby right um
right so uh so basically what happened
is we were like all right you know what
we're gonna like do a little bar crawl
and we're gonna go to some thrift stores
and we're gonna pick out outfits and
then you have to wear that outfit for
the whole day right
so uh I had a
a jacket with a little Fedora
um and I had this like short sleeve kind
of breezy shirt underneath and then some
some pants I got and then I had another
friend who had a mullet he had this like
uh kind of track suit jacket with like a
party
um
uh fanny pack you know
um so definitely business in the front
party in the back oh yeah totally
totally so then we have you know then
um basically everyone that was there it
was like six of us or so and we all just
picked found an outfit went to brunch
went to bars went around we had other
friends who were just living in Portland
now so we're seeing them as well
it was pretty somebody says uh
we're pretty woke AF up here in Portland
for sure yeah I mean Keep Portland Weird
right Keep Portland Weird so anyway on
my journey King cared wokers as Senator
Kennedy said oh no one had pink hair
though but it wasn't neon it was a neon
it literally said party bright neon
fanny pack
um
but uh I went to I went around I was
trying to find something I was like
Miss Miss then I finally got to another
spot I showed up I was like I'll get
this shirt okay we'll do that and then I
found this hat right I found this hat on
the rack
and I was like oh this is pretty cool I
like this
uh hold on quick side note funny story
we did find assless chaps inside of
Goodwill wait wait what what what what
are chaps if they're not assless I mean
that's that's I mean it doesn't bear
[__] in the woods I don't know why
people call them assless chaps they're
all assless I don't know if you've ever
seen Champs before and I get Kent your
sentiment it's bare ass cheeks out of
the chest right right yeah but there's
no such thing as is ass chaps right yeah
yeah they're always they're always
they're chapping you know right that's
that's the point of chaps you're not
trying to protect them you're trying to
protect Frontier I would even go as far
to say that Matt schlapp loves
some Ashley chaps wait is he is he
shapless chaps is he yeah he might slap
slapless chaps so anyway we go to we go
to this uh we go around we're looking
we're looking we're looking I can't find
anything and I finally get to a spot I
grab a shirt I see this hat I'm like oh
that's pretty cool so I go up to the
front the guy's like uh well the shirt
has a small little stain so you can have
the shirt for free I was like great you
know and then the Hat was like eight
bucks so I was like this is a pretty
cool hat I'm gonna look into it right so
I look into the company only to find out
that the company closed I'm assuming
during covet from what I saw okay I see
so this is
right so they no longer exist which I
was like oh man that [__] sucks I
would love to like get some other stuff
so then I was like well you are a
designer yeah I was like well I I kind
of I'm like in love with this hat right
now like there is no better sentiment to
be like I mean you know also a lot of us
are the children of immigrants this
whole country is basically uh everyone
who came here are immigrants
um I mean other than indigenous people
right exactly
but for anyone who came over right
you're all immigrants despite the fact
that a bunch of white Republicans are
like oh man we took the lane we This Is
Our Land is shut the [__] up dude
so I saw this hat and I was like I love
it this is great looked it up was like
[__] they no longer exist and then I was
like you know what I'm going to make a
son of an immigrant daughter of an
immigrant child of an immigrant just
like little merch notes so just like
just like a nice little like boom this
is who I am this is this is a part of me
this is a part of my DNA my identity
um and I'm sure a lot of people can
resonate so I was like all right I'm
gonna
I'm gonna make a little I'm gonna make
some shirts and you know different stuff
and have perfect yeah perfect I I like
the Hat yeah I like the Hat I like I'm a
big fan of that yeah because I'm not the
son of an well on my mom's side it's
like 400 years they've been here some
stupid [__] you have like a little
asterisk there they were well they were
the they were the they they're the um
the institutional white supremacy that
side of my family the other side is um
from
um Poland and they came here in the
great migration in the late 19th century
so I got like two halves one that's been
here oppressing
um indigenous people for hundreds of
years and I mean that's just I mean look
what am I supposed to do this is part of
the history I've got Spanish I've got
Spanish on my side as well so there's a
part of me that came and did some very
bad stuff to it right another part of me
you know right so whoa whoa so you're at
war with yourself in history is that
what you're saying yeah yeah I I feel
like there's a dueling going on all the
time inside me is that what's wrong with
you yeah that's one things look there's
a long list we don't have to get into it
today
let's not do the therapy session uh
today let's leave that for another day
let's do this let's go to the [__] list
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends I got a clip I
want to show you I don't think you've
seen Gabe Sanchez let's start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
y tweets and trendy trends of the day
you know I said the other day I wanted
to change that but I like that a lot it
is pretty cool like a lot of hype a lot
of hype for it you know I like that it
makes Twitter seem pretty cool it does I
mean
I seen that clip from The Daily Show
last night oh did you did you watch it I
I haven't watched it
man hey what what do you want from me
last night I was busy I I was yeah yeah
yeah drinking and singing oh that's
right it was karaoke night yeah it's
[__] Wednesday yeah all right okay
I'm not hungover this morning though I
only had I think there's only five shots
a Jager oh no three or four shots a year
I think is what I had that was it that
was it and it was spanned out through
the night so oh okay okay make sure you
have some water between that's the key
hydration
for the intoxication it's the nights
where
um people are giving me more shots than
just my Jaeger because the nights when
I'm I'm here like on Thursdays all
[__] hungover and [__] I'm not
hungover today not today unfortunately
um unfortunately well the things we're
gonna see you might want to be hung over
you you probably want a drink or two now
this first one now we're gonna get to
see pack I promise we'll get to these
seat pack clips and they're probably
rolling in as we're speaking because
there's no way these dumb [__]
aren't doing stupid [__] and enter in
CPAC right now and saying dumb stupid
[__] as we're speaking but you know what
we'll get to that and we got tomorrow
too with bone in the week I'm sure
there's going to be plenty of [__]
boneheads oh yeah and I'm sure some [__]
on stage come out of just the video
clips we're gonna watch today right I'm
sure I'm sure there'll be plenty of
[__] uh fascists trending for saying
stupid ass [__] speaking of fascists
saying stupid ass [__] this is in
Missouri my own state of Missouri this
is representative and and Kelly
is her name she's introducing this bill
to discriminate against people she wants
to take the Liberty away from people she
wants the freedom Gabe Sanchez to
oppress the rights of other people and
how she wants to do it is wipe them out
of existence in the classroom in
Missouri you've heard of the don't say
gay bill down in Florida this is
Missouri's version of don't say Gabriel
I have a feeling yeah
you know I'll say this and I'm going to
do a what was that on it it's the um
the Missouri one or just in general just
in general okay just like the theme of
you know the general sentiment of let's
get rid of let's legislate these people
say you don't exist right hypothetically
that's the I mean
here no evil see no evil speak no evil
exactly but uh no I was thinking about
this the other day and I was like more
and more people
are having [__] come out about stuff
they've done in the past right just oh I
got you one of those oh I got you one of
those and I believe you know like
Republicans want to get rid of like they
they want to get rid of drag shows trans
people gay people whatever like they
themselves have a drag problem man
there's like four different people now
yeah Rudy Giuliani you got George Santos
you got [__] Governor Lee and then
you've got the new guy the
representative that introduced the
legislation I just saw the video
yesterday of him in you know dress up
we'll call it
uh I'm just like was he wearing assless
chaps and I'm just I don't know maybe on
a different video I haven't seen no but
I can't tell you like I would imagine
that more and more people are gonna have
this [__] come out of the closet about
what they've done oh well you know the
skeletons or the you know I know I don't
think your pun was intended there but
that is the re what they're trying to do
they're trying to criminalize being gay
trans
bisexual lesbian
um and and they've already they've
already made it illegal in Most states
for you to have any kind of choice over
your over your uterus if you're a woman
so they want they want to extend that to
other people and other groups to make
sure that they can't be who they want to
be and have the choices that they want
to have but it's backfiring on them
spectacular oh every um everything they
do is a backfire well it's a mystery 23.
it's 2023 we know better than this [__]
now this is hilarious this clip here
because
well just [__] listen it's it's not
even worth me explain just listen it's
it's self-explanatory when they start
questioning uh representative and Kelly
that fascist about a bill therefore we
must keep our educational instruction
pure without the political nuances who
is Martha Washington
his wife
under your bill how could you mention
that in the classroom
so to me that's not sexual orientation
oh showing a man get this get this Gabe
Sanchez when a man is married to a woman
or a woman is married to a man and she's
famous because she's married to someone
that that is not sexual orientation now
let me tell you how these [__]
are getting confused let me tell you
because you're going to see a video of
an [__] in Texas who dressed up as a
woman and now he's trying to pass a bill
to make it a [__] outlaw people
dressing up as a woman here's where they
get confused okay
the word sexual
has a couple different meanings
especially when you say sexual
orientation or you're sexualizing
something like a like a plastic potato
toy right exactly or an Eminem if you
get horny and want to jerk off to him I
mean oh you know yeah well you know
whatever
these creeps want to do
um but again they're getting words
confused and meanings confused but let's
continue to see how she explains to us
how Martha Washington being married to
George Washington somehow is not has
anything to do with sexual orientation
and how
two people of the same gender being
married how that is it's weird but let's
listen
really
so it's only really certain sexual
orientations that you want prohibited
from introduction in the classroom
language to make that better to make it
where you're not talking lately I didn't
introduce your bill okay
which sexual orientations do you believe
should be prohibited from Missouri
classrooms
I'll have a moral compass
and my moral compass
is compared with the Bible you can oh um
listen we do not give a [__] this we do
not give two shits about your more your
moral compass is a you problem lady yeah
it is a [__] you problem if that is
the struggles that you have it is a
struggle you have not we you do you do
not get divorced the rest of us to deal
with your [__] Compass problem right
it's not you come to work right you have
a curriculum you can't bring your
ideologies in right like if you want to
express your opinion sure but there are
certain facts historical facts there are
certain scientifical facts or scientific
facts however I don't know I figured
that's a republican
all right I just figured that's how
Republicans would probably say right
they'd be like oh scientifical
scientifically morals and difficult
facts anyway
I'm just trying to play play ball with
Republicans I'm trying to make up words
your language in I think I'm rubbing off
on you I think it's right now so you you
look at you know look you you come to a
place of work you you agree you sign a
contract right you say this is what
we're going to study this is what we're
gonna do this is what my Lane is okay
I'm not gonna bring new [__] into this
Lane that has been predetermined we have
planning sessions as teachers
so when you have to bring in well my
moral compass and my moral compass is
Guided by the Bible it's a guideline a
rule book if you will that [__] that
[__] no it's not all of you guys will
stick it up your ass there is so I have
seen so much everyone in the audience
here has seen you have seen so much from
Republicans and religious groups where
they misconstrue conflate they uh
manipulate they twist and turn the text
into their own interpretation right so
when you when people say well I've got a
moral compass and it's Guided by the
Bible that's a bunch of gray area
[__] because what happens is you
then get into semantics of what words
actually mean and what the meaning of
the text was but again it is not you
know uh dawned on me brings up good
point the Bible is not a constitution
right it is not something that says that
these are your rights and this is what
you have to do as a citizen of the
United States
you're gone you know what's funny about
that is our constitution protects us
from her Bible right but again I mean
the separation of church and state that
doesn't really exist anymore well and
that's what she's trying to do so this
representative here is trying to
introduce a bill where she does get to
interject her Bible and her religion
into the Missouri classroom and forces
her ideology on curriculum but let's
let's keep listening how she can explain
it because it's it's [__] awesome how
she stumbles over her own logic here and
you can believe something without and
without and without any man
shut up lady shut the [__] up okay well
she keeps going and then it gets better
putting that onto somebody I'm asking
about the language of your bill and how
it would permit the mention of the
historical figure Martha Washington
could you explain that to me
so what does she do why is she famous is
she famous because she's married to
George Washington
it seems like that would be a relevant
fact
in her biography yes
he's like he's like I mean yeah she is
the lady who was married to the first
president she was the first first lady
so like I mean when you're talking about
who the very first first lady is
she being married George Washington
would probably be a relevant thing right
I mean just the fact when you're just
speaking about hey George Washington
president of the United States chopped
down the cherry tree couldn't tell a lie
right but you can't you can't say
anything about the wife right you know
right and forget mentioning that he
owned slaves forget about you again no
don't say that [__] no no no no no can't
say that here like he was a great white
man with perfect teeth that were not
stolen from other people right wooden
they're like oh it's they're wooden wink
yeah like no they're not they're not
wooden no no that's a [__] lie to but
the old Marshall Washington thing yeah
sure we'll go with that uh that it
doesn't need to be in her biography but
let's let's continue it it's even better
could it be mentioned under the plane
when reading language of your bill
is that a no I don't know sure okay yeah
uh what about
are you familiar with the historical
figure Harvey Milk
no I'm not she doesn't know who Harvey
Milk is
now see this is this is the problem now
he runs through it and and and
um
we're gonna listen to it here but the
fact that she
knows who Martha Washington is yeah well
she's a white lady right but Martha
Washington could be any Washington's
wife oh no yeah no she she knows who
Martha Washington is is because she has
been institutionalized by white
privilege and white supremacy in this
country and the institution just what we
were talking about with George
Washington he cut down cherry tree he
couldn't tell lie and he's a great
person all the time he wasn't a slave
owner I swear to God yeah okay [__]
[__] George Washington was not
perfect [__] he wasn't he was
not the picture of of greatness in 2023
maybe then and it's part of our history
and we can talk about it but we don't
have to ignore the [__] facts so much
so that a person doesn't know who Harvey
Milk is I it it it is a a failure if
someone who went through our public
education system from kindergarten to
their senior year of high school would
never know who the [__] Harvey Milk is
and the significance
of Harvey Milk his political career and
his [__] assassination
literally if you do not know that you do
not know American history you are a dumb
[__] and and I I am a dumb [__] because
I did not know about the Tulsa Massacre
no clue no idea had no idea because I I
was bred in the in the institution of
white privilege that's the facts I I've
said this many times I've talked to a
friend of mine who is a teacher we were
talking about the Tulsa Massacre and he
said how why didn't we know about this I
said because we're White
because we're white that's the reason
why you know about George Washington
cutting down the cherry tree and he had
wouldn't either wasn't slaves teeth hell
no and he wasn't no slave owner he
wanted everyone to be free you [__]
break okay I almost feel like uh Ann
Kelly here would be the type of person
who would use the twinkie defense in a
legal argument uh to try to get out of
some crime right and for people who
don't know the twinkie defense is
directly related to uh to the
assassination of of Harvey Milk and the
mayor of San Francisco because the their
colleague who who killed them
said amongst many reasons and excuses
that he gave he said I was on a diet
exclusively at twinkies and the Twinkies
made me go mad and that's why I killed
them which is complete [__]
but I almost feel like
I don't know man if you were on a
Twinkie only diet you'd want to kill
someone I don't know I mean I'm not
saying that's the reason
and make you [__] right murder I feel
like she would be the type of person
that would would try to use that defense
and right and still not know but who
everything is well that's true I see
what you're saying so you're saying she
would use that defense and still not
even know Army milk right okay well
let's let's continue to see if she knows
if if she can have her memory jostle to
see who Harvey Milk is but you're gonna
be surprised by what else she doesn't
know it's [__] crazy [__] the first
openly gay
elected councilman in San Francisco
first openly gay elected politician in
the country
um he was never mentioned I guess in any
of your classrooms do you believe that
that story should ever be told in a
Missouri classroom I have no idea
gentleman because I don't I don't know
his story okay um are you familiar so in
other words until I know exactly right
if he fits my narrative I don't want to
say yeah so forget the truth but she
doesn't even know actually here's the
thing I don't even think that she would
even
review it she probably in her head goes
oh he was gay no not gonna do it can't
do it oh no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no wait a second if it
supported their agenda they certainly
would teach that [__] yeah if it's
certain if it teach if it if it was a
way for them sure she would follow their
bias in it with hesitation like every
heavy they would have to know everything
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying that's what she's saying is she's
not saying no or yes she's like look I
really got to know the story and see if
it fits my bias right to know if I want
children to be indoctrinated by this
story or not I mean she could watch the
movie it might help but she might be
uncomfortable with it well she probably
would she probably want to ban it okay
let's keep listening earlier with the
overfeld decision
because I don't I don't know his story
okay um are you familiar with the
oberfeld decision
no I'm not
[__] there is a [__] elected
elective in Missouri and Kelly she is
the majority caucus secretary okay the
Republican majority caucus secretary
she has no idea
no clue
the Supreme Court decision of oberfeld
no [__] clue are you [__] kidding
me yeah but that's not surprising right
like you got someone who who runs for
local Council of the school board
position or whatever yeah that's the one
they want to smash apart and she is she
has no clue well here's the thing if you
don't know what it is then you can't
acknowledge it ever existed well but
it's the same thing it's the same thing
with the Harvey Milk story once she
finds out how it fits her you goddamn
right I know yeah God damn right I know
and I want to get rid of that [__] I saw
someone in the comment and they made a
good point as kind of dark as it is uh
Harvey Milk was gay and he was murdered
so she'd probably be okay with that
and that's I'm telling you that is the
sad truth I'm telling you if she could
find a way to fit her narrative and
teach it the way it fits her narrative
just like we teach the George Washington
never lied yeah and and he didn't have
slaves it were wooden teeth not stolen
from his slaves then then I mean yeah
they certainly would spend any single
piece of history I mean Jesus Christ are
like the Civil War weren't about slavery
it was about states rights oh God yeah
the state's rights
did you see did you see that she was on
uh Sean Hannity again and she was like
you guys all misinterpreted what I said
okay I wasn't saying like no give me the
clip give me the clip she was on the
other shows on the other night well
while you're getting that I want to show
this one of her
um where she's doing a video here and
I'm gonna warn you it's really [__]
close up
it's really closed up oh see she's
telling her sob story again isn't she
well this is where she's telling the
story about the [__] how she was
accosted in a restaurant right yeah I'm
doing a I'm doing a what was that on
this because there are so much there are
so many lies that she tells in her story
as well as Sean Hannity backing her up
during this interview it's it's [__]
ridiculous because they always they're
playing is this the same is this the is
this a clip of that interview
uh
no I don't think so oh no I think yeah
yeah
it's no no it's a different clip oh okay
but it's the same story but this is the
clip I found this morning of her yeah
yeah she was on she was on uh the show
the first which I don't know this is
someone commented underneath this video
because I tweeted I'm just gonna throw
this out there here's what I tweeted and
after you see the clip you know what I'm
talking about I said cope you treasonous
[__] oh yeah [__] you that's
that's how I came at her I mean a lot of
people like oh you're being so mean
you're saying the [__] word yeah I
certainly am I think it fits this one
okay let's listen to how she's whining
and crying about people being mean to
her accosting her in public like she's
never done it before to an average
citizen a restaurant and this this woman
and her adult son uh why does she say it
that way
her a woman and her adult son I don't
understand I don't really get that well
I think I think she's trying to I don't
know I mean I mean in this story she
says adult science couple Sean Hannity
story she says a man right but you this
again I'm gonna tell you why this whole
story is [__] [__] it's made up
and I'll tell you why you know what you
know what is the best part though about
that is that makes it even better for us
that she's making this [__] up because
we're able to she made this up as some
sort of thing to [__] us feel sorry
for her and we're mocking her because of
it
that's the best part let's continue
mocking her even though it's really it's
I'm sorry about the close-up but this is
the this is the [__] clip I apologize
for the close-up finished their dinner
and decided on the way out they were
going to ruin it for everyone else
um and started calling me terrible names
and screaming uh at the top of their
lungs Fu Marjorie
oh she was were they wearing like white
Petty Yeti coats when they were doing
this I have no idea were they dressed
what I can say about this is one I don't
feel bad for you because of what you've
done but also again this whole story is
made up well let's keep with the made-up
[__] let's let's listen well you
know it's so disrespectful
um not only to me
um but also to the restaurant there's
staff and and other Pages I'm sure the
restaurant and the patrons and the staff
[__] agree with them I'm just saying
friends that are there having just
having dinner uh but this is who the
left is Jesse and you this is who the
left is uh speaking to Jesse Waters do
you know how Jesse where he got how he
got the Fox News and what he did for
foxy do you remember what he used to do
for Bill rightly
no no I remember how we met his wife and
I could tell that story a second Jesse
Waters used to accost people in public
with a [__] microphone and be loud
and [__] that was his that was his
shtick on the Bill O'Reilly show you
want to know how he met his wife had
sure absolutely he said on on the air
yeah he admitted to this his current
wife that he had an affair with who was
like an assistant producer of the show
at Fox News he had an affair with his
current wife and separated from his
previous wife so don't listen to Jesse
Waters whenever he talks about marriage
and the sanctity of marriage and all the
[__]
but
the way that he met his current wife is
that he would leak the air out of his
current wife's tires at Fox News and
then roll up and say oh do you need a
ride home what the [__] increase
wait not only did he do this he's
admitting to this yeah let's see if I
can find on okay well let's watch this
clip of uh Madge the petty Yeti here
talk to uh uh Sean Hannity about this
fake story uh apparently this is going
to give us the evidence is this the one
that gives us the evidence that it's a
fake story this is uh this is he uh she
went on to Sean Hannity and told this
story again
and then also push the idea that this
part is about how they need safe spaces
I I'm I'm not gonna harp too much I okay
I'm going to look at this Freeze Frame
again
I I don't do these things it just
happens this way this is just how it
happens I don't know what to tell you
let's listen specifically about what you
mean you're not talking about separate
countries or secession is that correct
that's right Sean and first of all I
want to thank you very much
okay alrighty I'm grossed out I'm just
this is gross as [__]
what so so is he trying to repair the
damage that she's done yeah because I
guess she doubles down on it that's my
guess well so what so if anyone uh isn't
aware she went on last week and talked
about this National divorce and even
people within her own party were like
Marge is such a [__] idiot all right
shut the [__] up do you remember what
happened even even Steve Bannon was like
do you remember what happened during the
Civil War
so the idea that she wants to come back
wait wait wait when you lose Steve
Bannon yeah when you've lost in your
effort of sedition like when you lose
the abandon in your effort of sedition
and trees into your oath you really are
because man because again we've talked
about the show but even Steve Bannon and
other Republicans understand how much
red states depend on Blue States for
federal money so when marching Taylor
grades like oh we should separate these
blue in these red States okay good luck
determining how they really are but if
you do separate them and you have these
southern states that separate from these
Northern blue States or whatever you're
going to find that those states are even
[__] over even more
so she comes on the show and she's like
oh well I I was attacked and I was
assaulted and Democrats are so crazy she
literally she goes they're so insane
and she tries to course correct and she
even did the audit and this is how much
she's trying to fix the narrow like fix
the the messaging
she went on not only this show but she
also went on Sean Hannity's uh radio
show to explain in further detail what
she actually meant and she don't you
know why that's important you know why
that's important did you know as much
weight as Fox News has Sean Hannity's
radio audience is almost three times the
size of his television audience did you
know that I did not know that yes way
bigger His Radio audience
way bigger
way bigger and that is why she went to
an extended version on his radio show
right so she goes on the show and she
tries to course correct and he tries to
help her by saying look that's not what
you meant right when you said National
divorce you didn't mean like a
separation of this and so then this is
this is I I don't know if she goes into
specifics but
uh she then talks about how we need to
have a safe space for republicans and
you are one of the only ones that
actually was willing to ask me what I'm
talking about everyone else just talked
about me and assumed what I was saying
because you literally said
you literally she's like oh well
everyone talks nobody this is the same
[__] that she tried the other day
when she had a little like video she
posted where she said you know people
twist my words because they see things
about me online you literally harass
kids you spread conspiracies your uh
anti-semitic you're racist you're just
overall bigoted there is nothing that
people make up about you
repeating what are you literally said
that well that's why she hates Patriot
takes yeah because Patriot takes would
go and get her Clips like she would
threaten to sue him and she yeah there's
a whole text message but she was like
crazy okay I'm gonna come after these
guys it's like but you you post this
[__] online what do you want me to do
I'm just clicking it you did an
interview they shared the interview and
then they found it and they clipped it
so if you're gonna get mad at anyone get
mad at yourself because you literally
were like hey I have these opinions it
would like me be getting me getting mad
at someone clipped our show and posted
online I'm like how the [__] could I get
I say this [__] out loud yeah for
thousands of people a year this whole
time no no
definitely not I got the mic turned way
the [__] up and it would be like me
getting mad even if someone like clipped
me and they have there there's people
who have clipped me
um to make it sound like I'm saying
something different the best part about
that and I think I pointed you out that
this the tick tocks I used to do they
were like clip [__] that I would say
like see see the Liberals they're
[__] crazy I'm like dude I was
mocking you yeah when the thing you're
clipping is the [__] I was mocking you
saying you dumb mother a [__] but you
know what are you gonna do that's I mean
I would love for them to keep clipping
me and trying to catch me you know Tony
Michael said this go ahead and because
I'm more than likely making fun of your
dumb ass when I'm clipping it so clip me
all you want but she's scared for people
to know what she says apparently let's
but let's listen what she says Civil War
accusing me of secession and all kinds
of things that's what you did talking
about is reducing the size of our
federal government oh here it is here it
is small government big government I
told you [__] we're going to
talk about small government big
government today because they don't know
what it is they have no clue I'm gonna
show you a clip from Scott Perry at CPAC
he has no idea that that big government
doesn't mean big buildings but let's
let's continue and giving more power and
control to our states to be the identity
that they want to be whether it's blue
or whoa whoa whoa with the pronoun stuff
lady easy on the states having their own
pronouns what the [__] is this [__] Gabe
Sanchez is that what she's suggesting
that States she's she is suggesting and
and what I what I do I don't mean to
mock it but that's what are you gonna do
what I love about this is that we there
is okay there was literally another
train derailment that happened in
Florida no you don't say you don't say
so if you were to say hey we want small
government which is exactly what Trump
was trying to do by cutting regulations
small government small small government
but we still want socialism they want
big government cleanup they want big
government cleanup small government
regulations small government [__] up
they want big government right clean it
up correct and so you look at you look
at Ohio you look at Florida you look at
all of these other problems it's because
they said whoa whoa we want small
government less regulation less
oversight
when we [__] up then we have the Big
Brother come in and try to fix the mess
that we made while Mom was away you know
we want to make sure that big government
props up the one percent exactly we
don't want them to protect the masses
right we don't want big government to
make sure to protect people's rights and
[__] no no no no no [__] no we don't
want that so when you when you hear her
say oh well I I wanna I wanna
they're talking about federalizing and I
want small small government and I want
uh there's all this over there's
spending in this and this like dude that
is no if you take away this [__] okay
you know what good luck do it find a
state Florida whatever do it over there
and I guarantee you within five years
that plays a [__] [__] show and it's
in a like a post-apocalyptic state right
you know what's funny about this more
than anything is what she's talking
about
in in truth
um because she's so stupid she's really
not going for a civil war she's too dumb
to she would just say Civil War right
right what she's tired or she probably
thinks Civil War means like civility
which is not what it means right well
what she when you boil down what she's
talking about here
um the sentiment really is federalism
and anti-federalism right right
um and what a lot of people especially
merge here doesn't understand that at
one point in our history there were
Federalists and Anti-Federalists in each
party right they were in each party
because each party believed that you can
use a certain way to do a certain thing
right but their goals were the same now
the craziest part is is that this
chucklehead can't explain this with that
with that line of thinking right but the
reason why I believe it was she's dumb
but no one in the audience and no one
she's talking to will understand what
the [__] she's saying they won't
understand it I mean we just saw someone
who didn't know who the [__] Harvey Milk
was but let's continue with the [__]
Petty Eddie here and see what she's got
to say for red because the division in
our country has gotten to a dangerous
point no no right no it isn't no it
isn't that's all [__] just because
there's 20 percent of the country that
still want to live in the land of
bigotry doesn't mean that we're divided
it just means that the land of bigotry
is heavily concentrated in areas where
people are [__] diluted and education
is [__] or more [__] than the rest of
the country get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense let's keep listening
experience it on a daily basis
um being attacked in public is no fun
but we also have to remember it's not
just uh says the person who attacks
people in public a tax AOC attacks David
Hogg uh attacks the president United
States during the State of Union Address
get the [__] out of here you are such a
lying sack of [__] selected members of
Congress or famous you know Republican
spokesman or political commentators like
you and others but it's also regular
people maybe people that were a mega hat
that have been attacked for years now
and we are fed up we're fed up with
Democrat policies we're fed up with the
woke ideology being shoved down our
throat and we're tired of our children
being brainwashed into these same ideas
um we want our own safe space and we
deserve it
there's such [__] snowflakes [__]
ass [__] the funny is a [__] safe
Space
full contact that's funny she goes on
Sean Hannity right and in the in the
beginning of the interview she's like oh
well thanks for having me on Sean and I
just want to explain like so the other
last night I was having dinner with two
I think it's what she said two
colleagues or something like that two
two people who work for her office you
know those people could probably
um say if this story is true or false
not I'm just right but they're not
they're not going to no they're not
going to but here's the other thing well
there's two two points I'm gonna make
and this goes into the what was that
that I'm that I'm working on right now
one
there is uh no way this happened for two
reasons if it happened she would have
recorded that [__] just like a split
second of it if she could she would have
pulled out the phone and recorded it and
been like you're you're in my space
you're attacking me you're attacking me
guaranteed she would have recorded it
she recorded everything right 2019 she
records herself herself she records
herself
berating and assaulting David Hogg
verbally as he's walking throughout DC
because she thinks that he's a crisis
Act Right wow she was clout chasing yeah
I mean that's number one number two is
at the beginning of the interview she
says I was busy having dinner and
working and preparing for my committee
assignments the next day
she comes on the show
those remarks that we watched the other
day yeah seemed a little the same the
same day the same day remarks where she
says
uh there was 11 Point whatever thousand
tons that was uh yeah four thousand
seized in 2021 but there was fourth out
4.8 000 ton or pounds that were seized
in 2020.
462 she can't say the number 525 600 man
you know whatever that Song is That's
What I merely had in my mind God damn we
need to find a clip and play that song
over a clip of her time
damn that's a good idea she goes on and
she complains about that but here's the
thing if you look at the outfit this is
the this is like the solid indicator uh
the outfit she also goes on that same
day she says oh I was busy working and
preparing with my staff right we're
having dinner working and preparing
but that can't be the case
because
she didn't record it but also if you're
telling me that is the preparation
amount which I'm also like I guess
that's possible when when she prepares
for committee assignments it consists of
not being able to read out numbers
using uh a grieving mother's uh kids
dead two two dead well the mother I I
would I would love to take time to dig
into the mother on that because the
mother's despicable in that regard I'm
not even gonna yeah
but the fact that she brought this woman
in from Detroit to say that Joe Biden's
failed policies are why her sons are
dead only to realize you know and Joe
Biden even called it out in a speech
which I think we should we should I
think we should play is Joe Biden is
like here's the thing that didn't happen
while I was present it happened in 2020
when Trump was president
who am I Marjorie Taylor green oh my God
I'm sorry I'm distracted I'm trying to
listen to your story but I can't help it
look at this Freeze Frame oh if that
ain't the where's the white coat now you
were pointing out the reason why I
brought this up because you were
pointing at her outfit so that was a
really busy day of stupid oh yeah it was
crazy and the other thing I want to
bring up is the fact that she says
Democrat policies that same day right
that same [__] day
Jamie raskin's like look it might be
like semantics are you guys not knowing
how to use the right word but there's a
difference between an adjective and a
noun and when you're using it like an
adjective it's Democratic democratic
policies Democratic plan Democratic
party but she goes in she goes the
Democrat policies
this is what happens when your education
system fails you
primarily because Republicans want to
ban books and cut policies and cut
funding and tell teachers that they now
have to go from attend student class to
a 30 student class and oh no we're not
going to pay you more or give you more
resources the same run down hand-me-down
uh uh crayons and paper and pencils and
all of that stuff and also good luck
because you're also babysitting
[__] [__] hey speaking [__]
look at these two [__] oh look it's
um one sexual right assaulter and
another one who covers up for a sexual
assault you know
it is kind of funny and I I what did I
say when did I I pointed out some here I
said I said sounds like Matt knows Jim
won't report sexual assault like but
listen listen to what he says about Jim
Jordan you talking about [__]
delusion oh my God this is [__] wild
[__] listen to what he says about Jim
Jordan there's a lot of chatter in the
media about who's here and not here I'm
really proud to be standing alongside
someone I think might just be the most
powerful man in Washington DC
no
the most powerful man who can never seem
to wear a a [__] Blazer or a jacket
you know what I bet the most powerful
man in Washington DC would already have
Hunter Biden locked up I'm just saying
I'm just saying [__]
he would have his [__] laptop in the
committee right now if the most powerful
man in the most powerful man in the
entire country would have Joe Biden out
on his ass in the White House front lawn
and Donald Trump moving right on in if
he was the most powerful man Jim Jordan
is a [__] dumb [__] he's an idiot he
doesn't know [__] about [__] and let me
just tell you something that you may or
may not know
he does not report sex crimes and I
think I believe that's why Matt Slap
loves him here that's what I'm thinking
um because as we know match lap is
accused of sex crimes did you know that
did you know there's an accident
and accusation against Massillon is it
more than one or is it just one well I
mean I thought there was a there was a
recent development on that story there's
probably more but here was his response
to someone asking him that question
let's see what he says or more
importantly doesn't say how it should
work
foreign
what's your response to the allegations
against you at this moment
[Music]
what are your response to the
allegations against you
see how he pulled Matt Slap to a
different day he's got a little uh a
little a little babysitter Nanny kind of
you know what's funny is they always
want to harp on Joe Biden when his
handlers are telling him what doors are
where and where they're going
um they always want to harp on him but
there's Matt Slap he looks really old in
that he looks like he's lost a lot of
hair I don't know it just means great I
mean look it's a lot of stress comes
from you know finding out that being a
[__] pervert and uh sexual assaulter
uh if not more you know who knows what
will it come out but the idea that
look look at what happened to Harvey
Weinstein right that guy's a [__]
creep he's gonna die in prison but look
at how like you know your health goes to
[__] when when you have that amount of
stress on you right like you're like oh
[__] I'm gonna go to prison I'm gonna
get [__] convicted of this uh uh you
know like just like the wear and tear of
stress and hate on your body
so it doesn't surprise me that
Republicans always look so old and
[__] hagged Hagrid you know hate hate
is a [__] right oh yeah hate
hate and racist like a [__] like that
type of [__] will age you I mean it's
also scientifically proven so right it's
[__]
um speaking of
um hate Scott Perry hates accountability
do you know Scott Perry is yeah not to
be confused with Rick Perry right
um uh Scott Perry is a congressman from
Pennsylvania he's the one that's working
really hard to make sure the Department
of Justice doesn't know what's in his
cell phone it's kind of funny it's kind
of funny Republic's like hey laptop from
hell we need to find out what's in the
[__] laptop and they're the ones
fighting in court to make sure that the
Department of Justice doesn't actually
see what's in their electronic devices
it almost feels like to me it's
projection but listen to Scott Perry
here project his his [__] Terror
of being held accountable for his
seditious crimes and then what
retribution he's going to bring with the
power that he has that now that he
blackmail Kevin McCarthy uh so that he
could be speak of the house listen
you can't buy a gas stove but that you
must buy an electric vehicle that you
can't go to work but you must put some
experimental potion in your arm and then
oh you you you can be straight but you
can't be gay you can dress up but you
can't dress up as a woman listen you
[__] you are the ones telling
people what they can and cannot do you
[__] scumbag what the how in
the [__] can anyone listen to this and
think that that government is trying to
tell you to get rid of your gas stoves
and forcing you to buy an electric
vehicle this is the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard of when the government the
Republican governments all around the
[__] country are trying to legislate
people out of existence you cannot be
gay you cannot be trans you're not
allowed in the state of Tennessee the
state of Texas the State of Florida not
only that we do not want children to
even read that you are a possibility we
want to wipe your existence off the
[__] can map you do not have the
choice of identifying or being the
person you want to be but oh but Gates
ninjas you're going to be able to buy a
gas stove it's going to be really
awesome I really need one of those we
got stoves right now it's going to be
[__] nobody better stop me from
buying a gas stove and I'm gonna let
that gas run into my whole house
let's let's continue with this asshats
logic here and keep showing up to do
that to visit your church and worship
our personal sovereignty is what this
nation was built on and it's the
foundation it is oh my God you are the
only people who are trying to take what
you are calling people's personal
sovereignty away from them you piece of
[__] garbage you fascist piece of
Maga trash you you [__] you you are the
only one who are trying to take away the
liberty and have the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people and take away
their personal sovereignty as you call
it you [__] idiot let's keep going
under assault by every single facet of
the government oh Jesus Christ we are
going to create a firestorm like if it's
up to me there's going to be a firestorm
these leftists these uh marks this that
that have prevailed upon the American
people and use the awesome power of the
federal government to cow us into into
fear in our homes
they've got to be put on notice they've
got to be quaking in fear they've got to
be worried they've got to be oh oh okay
so I get it I get it now I get it out
what he's saying is is all that [__]
about how the left is oppressing people
even though it's all [__] he is
convincing people that that's what he's
doing to you so when he does it when he
does it he's just getting revenge no
problem right yeah when we're trying to
legislate trans people out of existence
when we're trying to train we're trying
to legislate and lgbtq community members
out of existence it's just us getting
revenge for taking our gas stoves okay
that's it it's just Revenge that's it
don't pay attention no big deal it's
just Revenge let's keep going
losing weight because they're not eating
because they're worried that they're
going to end up going to jail for using
the awesome power of the federal
government did you do you think Scott
Perry looks a little thin to me I mean
he looks thinner to me
did you hear what he just said he said
we want people to lose weight because
they're they they can't even eat they're
so fearful does he look a little
skinnier to you I don't know he looks
like him why would people be fearful to
eat that makes no sense I well I mean
I'm thinking he's I'm saying this is
what I know this for sure Scott Perry's
having trouble eating he's having
trouble sleeping at night because the
doj is going to get the contents of his
phone and when they do this
motherfucker's gonna go to federal
prison that makes sense right that that
part makes sense it's projection and I'm
just saying dude Scott eat a [__]
couple cheeseburgers something chill out
there it it's gonna take a year have a
have a you know have a [__] coconut
smile Big Mac or something I'm sure
Trump will buy you one well you know
here's the thing Scott I just want to
let you know this
um it's gonna take several years for you
to get to your trial to get convicted
and then actually be sentenced to prison
she got a couple more years of wandering
around acting like an [__] before you
go to federal prison it's all right
right so not to eat eat man it's not
gonna kill you eat I know yours have
your last meal whatever it might be but
right you know feed yourself enough that
don't I mean if you want a stress seat
that's on YouTube but uh
you might want to put something in your
body homie let's let's well because he
he definitely won't put a magical potion
in his body
let's see let's see what else he says
here because he projects oh this is this
is fantastic when he says how he's gonna
intimidate the Department of Justice and
not Prosecuting him that's what he's
saying here listen and if they're not
interested in showing up in Mr Jordan's
here and you know what
I'm in charge now and the transportation
Committee of federal leases huh
okay for folks that don't know in the
transportation committee when you're in
charge of federal leases that's where
you have the say of the government
leasing buildings so like when you see
the Federal Bureau of such and such in
in let's say Kansas City Missouri or or
Los Angeles or wherever you know that's
the that's the headquarters for that
City's agency
um more than likely the federal
government doesn't own that building
they're leasing it they don't actually
own it it is federal property because
their agency is leasing that but they
lease it and what Scott Perry is saying
is he might be in charge of that now and
let's see how he's going to use that as
a tool to make sure he's not prosecuted
let's listen huh and that's something I
wonder whose leases might become well
we're taking a look at the list it's
going to be awesome when they go from a
big building to about oh I know that
space on the Square there uh Todd that
would be awesome wouldn't it I love it
like we got a fight on every corner
ladies and gentlemen
so that's what he's doing the other
thing that he's doing here is playing
into this small government big
government thing where these stupid
[__] chuckleheads think the big
government is a big building oh like
they're adding on to a building or some
[__] like that's how big government
works like oh man they must say a lot of
Bill and that government's big they must
have a lot of warehouses that government
[__] idiots he's such a [__] idiot
he's so he's projecting so hard listen I
want the government the big government
to come for [__] Scott Perry's little
government ass and I want them to find
out what's on that [__] cell phone
and they're going to Jack Smith is going
to win that [__] battle in court
trust me he's gonna win it it's just a
stall tactic for Scott Perry while he's
losing sleep and losing his appetite and
Getting Thinner and thinner [__] that
guy okay um
do we have any other do you have any
other seat pack clips that you want to
show because I have a few others no I
didn't have any I didn't have any at the
at the okay top my head right now well
let's let's skip back uh here just a bit
and because I want to go back to um this
guy in Texas uh that talks about this
legislation where he dressed up as a he
dressed in Dragon now he's trying to ban
drag queens but before that before that
I want you to tell me if this is a drag
queen or not I'm not really sure I can't
uh I can tell no no that's uh that is I
think that's I can't is this a is that
the is that the ghost is that the I'm
trying to think of this from
Ghostbusters or if that's from
Poltergeist oh God it was the Crypt
Keeper within a like it could be the
criminal it's been a minute since I've
seen it I can't you know say for sure
yeah listen they're losing the plot
every day this is kellyanne Conway
basically going on Fox News begging
people to believe their lies this is
[__] hilarious listen it's Relentless
to the point where I want to challenge
people watching tonight who don't wear
red hats don't consider themselves Maga
don't consider themselves very strong
political people okay so she assumes
that there are people who religiously
watch Fox News that are not Mega like
what the [__] there's like five people
that are watching that aren't that are
cutting clips for the rest of us to see
I mean do I do I need to remind people
that this is the woman who went on to uh
I think it was MSNBC she was a con she
was a listen she was a paid contributor
on MSNBC by the way but during the Trump
Administration early on early on after
Sean Spicer said it was the biggest
crowd at the inauguration which
verifiably with photo like Photo
evidence it was not and well well you're
saying that was a lie I'm saying that
there are alternative facts is what I'm
saying okay all right well is that what
she said yeah and then and then I forget
who the correspondent was it was Chuck
Thompson yeah and he's like alternative
facts what and then she's like uh look
he told something that was not the
accepted truth of other people but it
was an alternative fact it's like right
I'm sorry uh those don't exist
alternative fact means a lie right it
means you're lying [__] well listen to
what she says this is great let's keep
going because oh man she's just like
getting on her hands and he's begging
these people believe their lies I want
you to ask yourself how many times
you've been lied to
wait wait wait wait wait wait literally
she's in this conversation she's asking
she is asking the Fox News audience to
ask themselves how many times they've
been lied to holy [__] can you imagine
how many times it would take forever for
them to count up all the lines that
they've been told as they're watching
Fox News I mean I think I think it would
be pretty pretty effective if they had
like the Sean Hannity kind of like role
where oh yeah yeah all the crimes that
trip look at all the crimes that Trump
committed yeah and like thanks for the
reminder right maybe they should just
have that like as a feature on their on
their uh their platform you know yeah
they just kind of sidebar I think they
just show all the lies they tell yeah
right just new stuff new stuff new stuff
to add to it oh it keeps getting better
let's go not just by this government but
how many times you would lie to by the
people whose job it is to tell you the
truth in the media
makes you run straight into it
so literally the people who are watching
Fox News are all listen listen to me
folks are only watching Fox News
and here this dumbass is sitting here
telling the audience hey how many times
have you been lied to you by like uh the
news network that you watch like what
the [__] are you [__] listen when I tell
you they're losing the plot this is what
I mean they are losing the grip on where
they were headed because they don't have
a long-term plan folks their long-term
plan is not some grand scheme it is just
to keep chipping away at liberalism
until they have fascism they have no
long-term strategy there's no long-term
plan and they are losing the plot I'm
going to show you a clip from Ron
DeSantis I hope I get to it I'm showing
you they're losing the plot and they
don't have a good site and there's not a
light at the end of the tunnel for them
well I think I think for a lot of it
it's they have this idea of what they
want to they what they want to have
right what they want to achieve which is
that you know they want to take away
your rights they want to keep their
rights they want to look at that
screenshot
uh that freeze frame is Magic nobody
take us nobody go back nobody take a
freeze frame of this and do something
with Tony
uh that's a challenge for anyone
watching take a freeze frame of this
moment
and then put something in there you go
Tony there you go you [__] internet
trolls you said something anyway uh it's
funny it's funny because
what the the best like kind of analogy I
can come up with here is that they know
where they want to go right they know
the ultimate like destination
but they have no map and they're just
kind of like well we're winging it right
and we're like well I think this is
north and I think this is this you know
they're they're trying to find their way
without Google Maps or MapQuest or uh an
actual physical map they're just kind of
doing it by the field like the [__]
Cedar pants right
um they're trying to get to this end
this end goal which is fascism right
they don't want to call fascism but it's
fascism right they want to get there but
they don't actually have a road map
despite the fact that they could look at
what happened historically in the past
well I think there is one of them that
has a road map oh yeah but but he yeah
oh I'm gonna show it to you okay but
first I want to do this
um I'm going to disappoint Nancy here
unfortunately Nancy on Facebook says
she's married to George complete
opposite politics George Conway is not
complete opposite Paul George Conway is
a [__] scumbag I don't know if you
know that but he is a scumbag and he has
fought he has fought the the policy of
overturning Roe v Wade you can think
pieces of [__] like George Conway for
that okay you can do you can also think
uh I mean like you have to if people
need to remember like he is with the
federal Society he is part of these
people who are forming legislation you
look at other people who are on the
bench the Supreme Court those are
federal Society members who are going to
push and make sure that they are
supporting the policies and the
legislation that the federal Society
wants to have right you look at
um
why am I blank handmaid's tail lady why
am I blinking her name right now oh Amy
Coney Barrett yes Amy Coney Barrett
right she's another one the reason that
we had that forced through like you had
a bunch of these people who were from
that Society working with Trump and
senators and others people like George
Conway are the reason why we have Trump
right 100 full stop that is the [__]
reason why we have Trump and and just
because they because there's plenty of
pictures out there in 2016 of George
Conway and Maga hats and he was really
excited when Donald Trump won don't get
that [__] twisted yeah they just
don't agree on Trump right well just
just because just because Donald Trump
wasn't loyal to them and they didn't
show their loyalty to him doesn't mean
that they're not scumbags speaking of
scumbags here's the one that I'm telling
you has a road map and he's laying it
out in Florida this guy's trying his
best to be the um the fast the Florida
fascist the Hitler in the making listen
to what he says here this is crazy [__]
man oh my God this is gonna absolutely
ruin Ron DeSantis let's listen there was
one uh yeah there was a proposal uh that
I think a lot of us wanted to see under
the prior Administration to to do a
schedule F so anybody that has any
policy role is classified as a schedule
F and they can be removed uh by the
president okay so do you remember this
um it was the very end of Donald Trump's
presidency right and he was preparing to
try to win because I actually think that
is the reason why he's so [__] upset
is because people around him like oh
yeah you're gonna win oh no no way they
were fluffing it which is the difference
which is completely different when he
won in 2016. right no one on the team
knew that he was going to win or thought
he was going to win not even he did and
when they announced oh Donald Trump won
the 2016 election it's terrified
the other thing too is that everyone was
like where the [__] is Trump where like
Omarosa was like where's Trump where's
Trump and he had no idea or expectation
that he was actually going to win right
well um so the schedule laugh thing is
where the president United States can
basically undo the entire bureaucracy
and what I mean by that the bureaucracy
are people who work for the government
uh as a career not as appointments okay
now there are some people in the
bureaucracy that are appointed like um
the Postmaster General we know the
Postmaster General is the joy and we
would love to have that [__]
skated out because he's done such bad
[__] but you can't the president United
States cannot just fire The Joy he just
can't that's not a purview of the
president and the reason why is be
because of how the Constitution set up
for the Post Office and I mean there's a
whole thing but that's why Ron DeSantis
is using he wants to use a schedule F
listen to what he says about it listen
to what he loves about it this is the
most important part the left would
litigate that but I honestly think we
would win on that in the Supreme Court
and I also think it's one thing to have
some type of job rules for the the
bowels of the bureaucracy like your
supervisor what they can do president
United States has Article 2 power who
controls the executive branch right is
it the elected president or is it some
bureaucrat in the bowels of the
bureaucracy that can't be fired and so I
think push needs to come to shove on
this but whoever gets a majority of the
Electoral College is has the right to
impose their agenda okay so do you
notice his language there this is
[__] super important folks and and I
don't know if Trump's going to season I
hate Liz Liz Harrington I know you're
listening to our show you always listen
to our show I know you're listening
because you took our suggestions for
your your movies she's always listening
right she's always listening so hey Lids
um just a personal side note I no one
else hear this if you're listening right
now just I like producer credit on your
[__] right yeah sure yeah that that we
would like credit for all the changes
they've made but here's I'll make a
suggestion for you this is where you
call Meatball I want to be dictator this
is this is where you do it Liz this is
where you do it because I really want
Trump to go after Ron desantos as a
dictator wannabe I don't know how much
louder he has to say it he literally he
literally says I'm not gonna there's no
Republican that's going to win the
popular vote he knows that he knows an
authoritarian in this country
is not going to win the popular vote no
[__] way no [__] how he says the
person who has the most Electoral
College votes gets to have ultimate
power in the executive branch
and gets to be an authoritarian because
they have Article 2 power is what he
says and he doesn't say by the by the
will of the people that's not what he
says not by the will of the People by
the will of how they win which I think
the last Republican that won by popular
vote was George Bush in his second term
am I right am I correct and I think so
yeah now the last um last all
Republicans he's the only one something
like that the point is this Ronda Santos
knows that the will of the people is not
going to be the way a republican is
going to win he [__] knows it he says
it right out loud and then he says when
the Electoral College picks me to be
your president I'm gonna do whatever I
want and I'm going to just I'm going to
dismantle your entire government yeah
that you didn't vote me in for
that that the technicality voted me in
for right it's it's something else man
let's watch let's listen to a finish
here this is crazy [__] through the
executive branch right and even Mark
Levin's a little uncomfortable here I
have to admit he's like oh [__] man oh
my God what are you gonna do now whoa
son of a [__] I don't know if you guys
know who Mark Levin is he's another
[__] a piece of garbage that has a
three-hour talk radio show that has a
much bigger audience than what he'll
ever dream of having on Fox news but
even he's really uncomfortable with this
they did what president Trump was
basically try to nullify the election
through not only bureaucratic
intransigence but malfeasance with the
collusion hoax and some of those things
and so reconstitutionalizing government
starts with reconstitutionalizing the
executive branch under article two did
you hear what he just said he just said
re-constitutionalizing
he wants to redo the Constitution folks
meaning he wants to trash it I don't I
don't I don't know
that's going to play off so well with
the rest of the constitutionalists
well um Mark Levin the guy who
interviewed him the reason why he's
probably really uncomfortable is because
that guy says the word constitution more
than anyone else I've probably ever
heard say the word [__] Constitution
I used to listen to Mark Levin oh my God
what trash I couldn't even get to I
could get through about an hour and a
half of Hannity I could do before Trump
I could do three hours of Rush Limbaugh
because I could yell and scream at the
radio but Mark Levin I couldn't turn
that trash on for more than 35 minutes
and I'd have to turn that [__]
garbage off he's horrible he's a [__]
He's horrible he's garbage speaking of
garbage just listen to this guy down in
Texas he's a legislator I forget it oh
his name's Nate his name's Nate
sounds sounds like the name of it I
think I think it's short for Natalie I
honestly think it's short for Natalie
because listen
what's going on this is representative
Nate schatzline and here we are it has
been what's with the bam bam bam bam oh
I'm so hip oh my God I'm appropriating
culture that I want to get rid of what
the [__] are you serious you
[__] you you [__] are
trying to are trying to get rid of black
history and States yours included and
you're you're appropriating black music
in your [__] stupid little social
media videos where you're gonna spread
your propaganda your bigotry get the
[__] out of here oh my God I would be so
[__] pissed off is this Snoop Dogg
song is that a Snoop Dogg song yeah dude
I would totally I would torch this
[__] Snoop Dogg snoop snoop did
you know this did you know hey call him
up call him I know you got Jordan see if
George yeah because you also have to
remember that that Snoop Dogg bought the
bought the rights and also the record
label death row and and took everything
down from streaming so the fact that
he's playing this song right now doesn't
seem like it's so good I'm gonna get
knocked for having it on the show even
yeah 100 YouTube's gonna block this
video for many monetization
right if you're uh watching well it
depends on how they do the copyright
yeah I don't know I don't know if Snoop
silences it or he's just like uh you
can't make money off of it I'm not
really sure
My Librarian says George Sanchez
actually wrote the lyrics ah
yeah he actually George Santos this is
this is actually a an unknown or a
relative rather uh not well-known fact
right uh George Santos is a profound
ghost writer for many hip-hop artists
and rap Legends in the game
um you'd be surprised how many Classics
he actually uh you know uh that that he
wrote for Dr Dre Eminem Snoop Dogg 50
Cent you know
Kanye West in the later years let me
tell you
um
uh she even proclaims a legit fact I
swear
um she is the mighty librarian so um she
is Herb she is our local fact Checker
because she's a librarian she's akin to
all the source materials so but let's
let's listen to The Stolen music and the
words of this [__] let's listen
interesting week a very interesting day
as left-wing news media has done exactly
what they do and that is Twist stories
to be something that they're not look
okay I I have to say look I um I know
Liz is listening for the benefit of
Trump's videos but Nate if you're
listening dude turn the music down so we
can hear you talk like literally man
it's just background music I don't play
background music yeah it's it's well I
mean part of me is like great I don't
have to listen to your [__] right
here right but but but yeah it the other
thing that I find funny is um
is how much
like her him and Margie Taylor green
right they use songs from you know uh
from smokers wokers right and so they
they play songs by people that promote
misogyny in drugs in alcohol and this
and that and then that's the party
that's like uh-uh we're trying to lock
down on that [__] this guy Nate is the
kind of guy who would go up during a
um
a talent show let's say or would make a
video right I'm surprised he didn't try
to rap the lyrics to the song in a very
corny way but it was like what was that
Tic Tac Trend recently where you were
talking the words oh that was Nicki
Minaj's song because the beginning was
like it was she tells a story in her
song and so then you're telling us yeah
but it's this idea that that they that
they appropriate or they take songs from
these artists that have
imagery or lines in their songs that
they would wholeheartedly disagree with
in public right so the fact that he's
playing this song right now is [__]
it's hilarious but also it's just
Gary Gary points out Gary here on
YouTube he said it I didn't all right he
says as a gay guy I'm thinking he is too
Gary what what evidence
um gives you that idea I I'm I'm curious
I don't have a very good
gaydar to be quite honest with you I
just I just don't
um but let's
let's finish up what Nate says about
dressing up in drag he dressed up in
Drag
he he put woman's clothing on and he's
saying it's different I think he's
saying is different let's listen the
left wing is attacking me because of
some class project I did as a teenager
where my buddies dared me to wear a
dress but we're not going to let that
distract us what wait wait wait it was a
it was a class project where his buddies
dared him
to what was that to dress up a class
project where my buddies dared me to
dress up
but we're not going to let this distract
dress up as what I'm going to be honest
with everyone here whenever I had the
opportunity to do a class project that
was a video I [__] took advantage of
that [__] 100 of the time right but I
want to point something out 1.7 I know
listen to the subtitle look at his
subtitles
project I did as a teenager where my
buddies dared me to dress up but we're
not just going to distract listen to the
words those are the subtitles listen to
the words last project I did as a
teenager where my buddies dared me to
wear a dress but we're not gonna wear a
dress I'm sorry we're dressed so not
dress up as a woman wear a dress he's
very specific about that and it's his
buddies this is this is like locker room
stuff Gabe Sanchez
I really didn't have it in my mouth it
was a dare and it's like dude it doesn't
want to do there's nothing wrong with
that but don't try to then all of a
sudden be like oh no never never put
that dick in my mouth it's like right
just like except the Lord that's who you
want whatever man right whatever don't
don't [__] persecute other people for
this [__] now now I see I think what
Gary's talking about to be quite honest
with you I think I think I think I think
I smell what you're stepping in there
yeah yeah look I wouldn't I I have a
feeling Dr Dre is gonna send possibly an
another cease and desist
to this guy because remember this is the
same song that Margaret Taylor green
used
Still Dre when she got it taken down now
obviously he's not surprised Dr Dre owns
this song right uh
I believe so or is it I know snoop's in
it but yeah I don't know [__] I don't
know I don't know who owns it I don't
know I don't know how the rights
come down I don't know who the original
let's keep listening it gets it gets
Dumber let that distract us from the
real message of what we're trying to get
done right here in the Texas legislature
and that is Ban sexually explicit drag
shows and preserve the innocence of the
Next Generation in Texas look
look someone needs to check Nate's
laptop that's all I'm saying look look
yeah I'm gonna check these things out
I'm real into weird fetishes or whatever
and it's like uh dude shut up stop
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna make
a video viral video with a piece of
music that is going to absolutely make
sure that it gets banned from social
media so that way it doesn't get played
but Tony Michaels is gonna [__] play
it anyways he doesn't give a [__] if you
do takes it down doesn't give a [__] hey
Nate go [__] yourself buddy go [__]
yourself your stupid little excuse about
your friends daring you to dress up as a
woman and you liked it it's not gonna
play when you're trying to make it to
where a performer can't dress up in a
costume you [__] yeah you piece
of [__] and and to say that just
because someone who's who's gay because
this is what the [__] he's saying this
is what he's saying folks he's saying
that's okay because I'm not gay
I'm not gay I dressed up as a woman and
I'm not gay but
yeah the wink wink
um wink uh but here's the thing is that
when gay people do it that should be
illegal because that's sexualizing it
because obviously right anything a gay
person does just because they're gay is
is sexualized 100 I guarantee Nate was
on the lacrosse team and everyone was
getting naked in the showers and it was
like baby this is I'm [__] snapping
towels and I'm slapping acids yeah and
oops I touched a dick but that's fine
oops
Nate we're Fair here if you wanted to
come on and defend yourself you can come
on the show I know you won't because
you're a [__] [__] ass [__]
um that's why you're making the excuses
about you're like look I dressed up as a
girl in high school what the [__] you
what are you gonna do about it because
honestly I see nothing wrong with Nate
they're dressing up as a girl yeah
there's nothing wrong with that if you
want to make up even if you want to make
up some story about a class project and
your friends dared you all right that's
fine too whatever you want to do but
don't [__] be telling other people
that they can't do it Nate you piece of
garbage you piece of trash it is
man it is
unbelievable the amount of projection
and the amount of effort that
Republicans put in to take away rights
from a whole another group of people
right the fact is like you could if you
didn't like it's so dumb because well
Republicans need to realize and they
just don't realize is that their group
their voter base is shrinking by the day
those old white people dying off those
uh uh you're you have a small group that
are like actual of a marginalized
Community but even then you take away
their rights and some of those people
are so indoctrinated with the policies
because that's what they grew up with
that they stick with it but what they
don't realize
is that they attack the very people that
could help them win in future elections
right oh no I'm going to go against
instead of being like hey look I've
conservative policies fiscally
conservative I I don't believe that we
should have you know big government we
should have small government isn't that
like okay that that is what you believe
but as soon as you go and say oh you
know what I'm going to attack all of
these people right anyone in the that is
part of the trans Community anyone who's
gay anyone who who does drag anyone who
is uh uh Latino black Asian you know
whatever it might be when you see them
go after it's like you could have a
whole group of people in this country a
diverse group of people that could
support your policies and potentially
help you have better and greater buy-in
but instead you close them out and say
you're not actually a real human you're
not actually a real American because of
your lifestyle when on the you know the
flip side of that coin is Republicans
are the ones who are doing that behind
closed doors right we have many of them
like match slap who are sexually
assaulting other people we have Jim
Jordan who covers up sexual assault on a
wrestling team we have Herschel Walker
who also you know is you know the
epitome of
Republicans fathers uh uh you know
husbands you have other Donald Trump
list of 26 28 I forgot what the number
is uh of people that he's sexually
assaulted Eugene Carroll like all of
these people Republicans are terrible
humans and again instead of just saying
like hey we should
we should be welcoming we should accept
you as my brother my sister as a
Christian would right they say no no
you're not actually you're like you live
here but you're not actually like a real
you're not actually american-american
you know right and and it's that they
they do that to themselves I don't feel
sorry for them one bit because what they
do is they push away people that could
have been in their in their in their
party but then they come either Center
or left and say oh [__] these people
actually accept me for who I am and that
is the most important thing that I
believe in that people actually see me I
think I think you're making a good point
and uh Loki I want to address and expand
on what Gabe's saying here to your your
statement not all drag artists are gay
I'm not saying right that they that they
are all gay what I'm saying is they're
using the justification is I'm straight
and I dress up as a woman as it's
justification the reason why they're
going after drag artists they're going
after drag queens they're going after
people who dress up or cross-dressed
whatever the [__] you want to call it
like Harry Styles he's he dresses up in
dresses and I don't think that's drag I
I don't know I I don't know the
technical definitions I I don't know and
I really don't give a [__] because I
believe it's a choice anyone to dress
the way the [__] you want to dress and
it ain't my [__] business if that's a
problem with me that's a meat problem
not a you problem hey here's what I will
say
the reason why they are coming hard
after drag queens
the one reason is because the the drag
artist the drag queen community and
people who support them support and our
allies of the lgbtq community that is
why there is not a drag
um uh venue Club out there that isn't in
support of their lgbtq community and not
a safe haven for the lgbtq community to
exist the way that they want to exist
that is why they're going after the drag
Community folks they're going after them
because they want to put lgbtq people
out of existence and the drag Community
rather it's whether it's gay people who
are dressing up as drag or non-gay
people or people who just support people
who like to go watch the shows people
who want to show up and have their kids
experience someone who's different and
who who enjoys being who they are to
show them how to read
and enjoy it and to be entertained by it
and to love to read they want to put
that out of existence folks they are
trying to legislate a group of people
out of existence and they're using this
drag queen drag hour drag clubs
cross-dressing whatever they can because
they are they are staunch allies of the
community that they do not want to exist
and that is the most important tenement
here it doesn't matter of the sexual
orientation of the person dressing up
the way they want to dress I don't care
if you're gay and you dress straight or
you're straight and dressed gay or
whatever the whatever labels you want to
put on it this is this stupid [__]
pronoun [__] the arguments that they get
us involved in with pronouns who gives a
[__] what your pronoun is if you don't
like if you don't want to call me by the
pronouns that you want to call that's a
you problem right and if it's someone
else's problem don't let it worry you
[__] them [__] them that's the motto of
the show so [__] them and that is that
is what they're trying to do they want
to legislate people out of existence and
it ain't going to stop at the lgbtq
community it won't stop there it won't
stop it drag it won't stop at trans kids
it won't it will not stop it books it
won't stop it won't stop at math it
won't stop it not killing public
education they're not going to stop just
listen to the clip that I played for you
just a second ago of Ron DeSantis
and how meatball wants to become the
dictator and King and he thinks Donald
Trump really [__] up when he didn't
become dictator and King and he plans on
doing it right well here's how you can
stop at Gabe Sanchez here's how you can
you can engage in your democracy and one
way you do it is come here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific it is
[__] free to subscribe to the YouTube
channel do not forget to hit the
Subscribe button hit like go share this
sumbitch that it doesn't cost you a
single nickel make sure to follow at
Tony Michael's pod on Twitter because
you're going to get to vote for
boneheads and there's going to be plenty
of them after CPAC today holy [__] oh
yeah we're gonna have a whole slate of
boneheads to pick from so don't miss
bonehead of the week pole later on this
afternoon this evening depending on when
the minor is remind us of it you can
vote on the YouTube channel on the
community tab or on Twitter you can also
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast for free 99 on
Apple Spotify and Google it's it's
almost like theft yeah I mean look I'll
pay you to watch unless right right you
know what you actually you can for free
pay to watch the Tony Michaels podcast
did you know that what you you can pay
money wait then who have I been paying
this whole time I know uh you go to
Twitch and you just log in with your
Amazon Prime account you just log in
with the Amazon Prime account
and you you
can give us your subscription it's you
get a free subscription with your Amazon
Prime account so we me and Gabe Sanchez
get Jeff bezos's money it's not a lot it
really isn't that much
they're not giving us it's like a couple
bucks but hey it helps out and it
doesn't cost you a single nickel make
sure to go to patreon.com also and check
out what Gabe Sanchez has over there
with what was that patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out my page too while
you're subscribing to Gabe's page uh the
Tony Michaels patreon.com the Tony
Michaels yeah don't forget I've got a
I've got a couple new episodes coming
out okay one on Mike Lindell I got
another one coming up Marjorie Taylor
green look at all those announcements
over on patreon too don't you yeah okay
great so there's a there'll be a
there'll be new stay up to date I'll
probably have some bloopers coming out
soon you know that's what I want to see
yeah yeah I want to see the bluebirds
we'll do it live I get to see I get to
see Gabe Sanchez all his mistakes
um and he gets terrified when he sends
me no no they're misspelled open that
one out I'm like dude we just change it
or even leave it the same people
pointing out and so I get to see this I
can't wait to see the bloopers of what
was that I haven't seen a lot of
bloopers of what was that to be quite
honest no one gets to see those yeah I
know you've always been hiding them
that's why I suggested you put them up
yeah I know so for those people who want
to see those bloopers and want to see me
make mistakes yeah and say [__] and
throw [__] around my room
and how about it because that is what
you'll get if you become a patron of the
the what was that patreon so and please
please do not if whatever you do
audience do not take the nickname that I
gave Gabe Sanchez in the front of the
show and continue that the hunk of
Mexican love please do not don't spread
that around that would be horrible if
you did that that would be really
immature and it would be it would be so
yeah so mean guys it would be me it'd be
very mean and you should not do that you
definitely should not same place same
time tomorrow bone end of the week don't
forget bone of the week second hour
Fridays
see you tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
's meal Barn head ass Beacon